hi my name is James Cole I'm a medical
laboratory scientist the diagram
represents what I learned about
molecular diagnostics during the past 40
years first life is nutrient dependent
also there is no defined boundary
between epigenetics and genetics that
fact is the basis for the precision
medicine initiative nutrient dependent
metabolic networks must be linked to
genetic networks and the energy
dependent physiology of reproduction in
all genera you probably already know
that the in eight immune system links
rna-mediated nutrient energy-dependent
physics and chemistry that's how
nutritional epigenetics is linked to the
conserved molecular mechanisms of
rna-mediated cell type differentiation
you simply put the immune system links
energy from physics and chemistry to
biologically based cause an effect in
the early years of my career I used
information provided by flame
photometers and spectrophotometers to
link physics from chemistry to biology
now quantum physics links epigenetics to
the Maya physically constrained
chemistry of cell type differentiation
which is the basis for molecular
diagnostics if cell type differentiation
was not by physically constrained by the
immune system no one could test from
what goes wrong unfortunately the
complexity of analysis at different
levels of examination has linked the
sun's anti-entropic virus idle energy to
hydrogen atom transfer in DNA base pairs
in solution
the speed of light on contact with water
has been linked to the bio physically
constrained chemistry of rna-mediated
protein folding molecular biologists are
not surprised to find that energy
dependent amino acid substitutions are
the link from the epigenetic landscape
to the immune system and to the physical
landscape of super coiled DNA in this
diagram rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions link super coil DNA to
protection from virus driven entropy in
all organized genomes what I've done is
to integrate claims from Darwin Einstein
Schrodinger and absense key simply put
Darwin's nutrient dependent conditions
of life come before nation natural
selection that's how Einstein math and
physics link Schrodinger's claims in
what is life two dubs and skis claims
about amino acid substitutions and
biodiversity in all living genera I
included citations to support the
representations in the diagram taken
together the citations show that
nutrient dependent micro RNA flanking
sequences link the life history
transitions of all marine invertebrates
to all vertebrates via the rna-mediated
physiology of energy dependent pheromone
controlled reproduction Schrodinger's
claims about the anti-entropic energy of
the Sun predicted everything including
in this everything included in this
diagram but like many others Schrodinger
knew little or nothing about virus
driven energy of theft
neo-darwinian theorists for example have
only recently started to consider virus
driven energy theft and the likelihood
that theft of energy links viruses from
mutations to all pathology requires all
theorists to revise their theories for
comparison anyone who assumes the energy
dependent physiology of reproduction is
not the link to buy a physically
constrained rna-mediated epigenetic
inheritance probably never worked as a
medical laboratory scientist they may
not know how to troubleshoot the
theories that led to their assumptions
this diagram may help theorists tell her
tether their claims to facts about
energy dependent RNA need cell type
differentiation the diagram is based on
scientific experiments which are tests
that attempt to produce accurate results
medical laboratory scientists are
trained to eliminate sources of error
before testing I learned that theories
are sources of error theories do not
link top-down causation from chemotaxis
to phototaxis by what is known about the
innate immune system metabolic networks
and genetic networks theories about
mutations and evolution are dead ends
that's why the dead ends are represented
in red color in the diagram everything
in red is linked from stress induced
virus driven energy left to pathology it
would be appropriate to think of
everything in red in the context of
blood loss in humans without the energy
dependent rna-mediated DNA repair that
links blood to the protection of our
work organized Gina
from virus driven entropy molecular
diagnostics would exist only in theory
thank you